l'union fait la force
c'est en tout cas ce qu'ont bien compris
les états européens divisée et affaiblie
après la seconde guerre mondiale alors
en 1958 avec le traité de rome 6 pays
s'unissent économiquement la france
l'allemagne l'italie les pays bas la
belgique et le luxembourg
il crée la cee la communauté économique
européenne c'est la naissance officielle
de l'europe mais aussi de l'assemblée
parlementaire des communautés composé de
142 députés s'étant fait l'ancêtre du
parlement européen son siège est établi
à strasbourg essentiellement pour des
raisons pratiques puisque cette
assemblée utiliser locaux d'une
institution déjà existantes le conseil
de l'europe alors en 1962 cette
assemblée prend le nom de parlement
européen
son rôle est d'abord consultatif et il
faudra attendre les années 70 pour que
le parlement obtiennent un pouvoir
budgétaire
le parlement va obtenir un rôle
budgétaire qui n'est pas encore énorme
mais il a la possibilité de contrôler
certaines dépenses frais des recettes
ils ne votent pas l'impôt il n'ya pas
d'impôt européen mais il peut contrôler
certaines dépenses
c'est en 1979 que le parlement européen
gagne enfin en légitimité démocratique
puisque les députés sont élus au
suffrage universel direct il passe de
198 à 410 il faut noter que à la tête de
ce parlement européen il ya souvent des
français en 58 après des traités de rome
le premier président de l'assemblée
parlementaire européenne était un père
de l'europe comme on disait c'était
robert schuman et puis encore plus
important symboliquement en 79 le
premier président du parlement européen
élu au suffrage universel tout une
présidente c'est simone veil -le encore
une fois une française au fil du temps
et
chaque nouveau traité le parlement fait
davantage entendre sa voix face à la
commission et au conseil des ministres
avec l'acte unique
en 1986 il obtient à nouveau pouvoir
c'est ce qu'on appelle la coopération et
avec le traité de maastricht en 1992
là le parlement passe à la vitesse
supérieure le traité de maastricht a
créé quelque chose d'extrêmement
important qui est la co décision c'est à
dire que désormais le parlement va
pouvoir légiférer à égalité des droits
avec le conseil et actuellement sept co
décision est vraiment presse que la boi
législatives normal
l'année 2009 marque les 30 ans du
parlement européen élu au suffrage
universel direct depuis l'europe s'est
considérablement agrandi avec 27 états
membres
après les élections de juin 2009 736
députés siégeront à strasbourg siège
officiel du parlement européen